Transcriber: gaith Takrity
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
بدأت حياتي المهنية في عمر ثماني عشرة سنة.
اخترت أن أدرس الإعلام،
لكن ولا مرة كنت أتخيل
أنه ممكن أن أكون أستاذة إعلام،
ومدربة في تطوير القيادة
وفن الإلقاء والخطابة.
لماذا؟
ببساطة هذه الصورة الذهية
قد تعرضت بأساساتها لهزة.
بنت صغيره في عمر الخمس سنين،
جاءت والدتها لتأخذها
من الروضة بفرحة ولهفة،
جاءت لتأخذ آخر العنقود.
وعندنا مثل شعبي يقول:
“آخر العنقود سكر معقود.”
لكن هذا السكر بكلمتين
من معلمتها تحوّل إلى مُر.
ابنتك فاشلة.
لم تفهم البنت ما الذي تعينة كلمة فشل،
لكنها فهمت تعابير وجه أمها التي تغيرت.
كبرت،
ست سنين، سبع سنين،
ثماني سنين، تسع سنين إلى عمر عشرة سنين.
في يوم، كان هناك اجتماع لأولياء الأمور،
جاء والدها ليطمئن على تطورها الأكاديمي،
وهو يعلم أنها مجتهدة،
لكن جاء ليطمئن عليها.
كانت تتوقع البنت
أن تكون ملامح أبيها سعيدة
لكنه فجأة يناديها قائلًا:
“أريدك أن تذهبي لآخر الممر
وتتكلمي معي بأعلى صوتك.
تكلمي، تكلمي، لا أسمعك”.
تسمّرت البنت في مكانها،
وكانت كل الأنظار عليها.
وسكتت.
في تلك اللحظة، ذلك الصوت،
صوت والدها صحّى فيها خوفها.
خوفها من مواجهة الآخرين .
كم واحدًا فيكم يرى نفسه مكان البنت؟
خوفه منعه من أن يقدم مشروعه في شركة.
منعه من أن يشارك رأيه خوفًا
من أن يستخف به الموظفون الذين هم حوله،
حتى ابنته أو ابنه مبدعين،
لكن عندهما خجل يمنعهما
أن يطورا من مهاراتهما الخطابية .
كم واحدًا؟ ارفعوا أياديكم.
كم واحدًا؟
خمسة، عشرة، عشرين، ثلاثين.
أنتم لستم لوحدكم.
واحد من أصل عشرين شخص،
ينتابه التوتر والخوف عند مواجهة الآخرين
من أطياف عمرية مختلفة.
وذلك حسب المعهد الوطني
الأمريكي للصحة العقلية.
علماء النفس ماذا يقولون؟
حسب دراسات علماء النفس
والتي نشرت في مجلة حدود علم النفس،
يقولون أن الشخص الذي يواجه خوف
وتوتر عند مواجهة الآخرين،
أو بمصطلح علمي أدق “الجلوسوفوبيا”
أي رهاب التكلم أو الرهاب الاجتماعي.
يعاني من فرط نشاط في جزء من الدماغ ،
يسمى بالفص اللوزي أو “الأميغدالا“.
وهو الجزء المسؤول عن الإدراك،
وتقييم العواطف الحسية والمدارك.
وبالمقابل الاستجابة السلوكية
عند الشعور بالخوف والقلق .
كيف ينعكس هذا الكلام على صاحبه؟
واحد،
الخوف من آراء الآخرين أي القلق الاجتماعي.
اثنان،
الارتباك وعدم الأداء بفاعلية ودقة.
ثلاثة،
قلة الثقة بالنفس.
وأربعة،
الانسحاب وعدم مواجهة الآخرين.
خمسة، وفي أقصى حالاتها،
انعدام الحياة الاجتماعية أي العزلة.
إذًا السؤال، هل يمكن تجاوز
هذا النوع من الخوف؟
نعم.
أنا هي هذه البنت التي بعمر خمس سنين،
انهزت ثقتها بنفسها من رأي المعلمة فيها.
وفي عمر العشرة سنين،
فضلّت أن تنسحب وأن لا تواجه.
نمر في مراحل عمرية يكون
تطور الإدراك عندنا تدريحيًا،
يسألني أحدكم، حسنًا، ما هو الحل؟
هناك أشخاص خجولون،
وهناك أناس عباقرة في مجالاتهم،
ولكن بمجرد ما يصبح أحدهم في مرحلة الحسم،
ويريد تقديم فكرته،
تذهب منه الأفكار وتتبعثر الكلمات.
كيف أتجاوز خوفي عند التحدث
أمام الجمهور ومواجهة الآخرين؟
كانت الإجابة على هذا السؤال أول خطوة،
لتحويل خوفي إلى جسر،
لا حاجز أمام طموحي.
خرجتُ إلى الشارع.
(تصفيق)
أول خطوة اتخذتها أني خرجت إلى الشارع
جمعت آراء الناس في المجال الإعلامي،
ما نطلق عليه vox pop
نتكلم حول مختلف المواضيع،
أعددت القصص الإنسانية
من مختلف أرجاء الوطن.
وأكملتُ المسار.
لكن هل يمكن أو يعقل أن هذا المسار كله ورد؟
ستجد الناس المحيطة بك
يحاولون أن يثبطّوا من عزيمتك.
فعلًا، في مرحلة معينة وصلت إليها
بعد أربع عشرة سنة من المجال الإعلامي،
وصلت إلى مرحلة أنه لا يزال يوجد إلى اليوم
أصوات تحاول أن تعيدك إلى الوراء،
و تجعلك لا إراديًا أن تنسحب.
قلت لا، وقررت أن أدعم
الجانب العملي بالجانب المعرفي.
أكملت الدراسات العليا.
أتى مَن يقول لي: “أصبحت أمًا،
إجلسي في البيت“.
لكن كوني أمًا كان محفزًا
بالنسبة إليّ لأتعلم التواصل الفعال،
فأصبحت عضوًا في منظمة دولية
تُعنى في تطوير القيادة والإلقاء والخطابة.
تريدون الحل، أليس كذلك؟
قلت كيف أتجاوز خوفي
عند التحدث أمام الجمهور؟
البداية من الخيال .
لم يكن من الممكن أن أصل لما وصلت إليه
اليوم والطريق أمامي طويل إن شاء الله،
إلا في الخيال أي صورة ذهنية.
أول من خرج بهذا المصطلح ودعا إليه
شخص يدعى “ليبمان”، lip من الشفاه،
ولكنه لم يكن يتكلم عن الكلام المنطوق،
كان يتكلم عن الخيال .
أطلق العنان لخيالك،
وارسم صورة ذهنية لما تريد أن تصل إليه.
بدأت مع فئة الأطفال في التدريبات .
كنت أحضر صورة وأقول لهم:
“أنظروا للصورة، ماذا ترون فيها؟”
من طفل إلى طفل، قد تتفاجأون،
مع أنهم كانوا بنفس الفئة العمرية،
لكن كان لكل واحد منهم تصور
مختلف عن الآخر .
ماذا يقول ليبمان عن هذه المدارك الحسية؟
يقول لنا،
“ليس ممكنًا أن يستوعب الإنسان
العالم بدفعة واحدة
بالارتكاز على الحواس الخمس التي نعرفها“.
لذلك يجب أن يوظف التصور والخيال عنده.
بدأت معهم بالصورة الذهنية عن أنفسهم.
يكون الواحد من الأطفال يُخَربش
ويعطيك رسمة كلها خرابيش.
بالنسبة إليه من الممكن أن يكون قد رسم
فيها سماء وأرض ومكوك فضائي،
لكن أنت كشخص كبير،
بسبب فرق العمر الذي بينكم
ستراها مجرد خرابيش،
لكن هل رأيي مهم؟
هذا الرأي الذي هزّ ثقتي بنفسي
وأنا في عمر الخمس سنين.
هل رأيي مهم لأدمر هذا الطفل،
ولا يمكن فعل ذلك.
المهم ما الذي يراه هو.
تكون البداية من عند الأطفال.
فمن لديه ابن أو بنت خجولين،
أنا متأكدة تمامًا أنكم تثقون في قدراتهما.
ولكن البداية في التواصل الفعال.
في مجالنا الإعلامي نتكلم عن رسالة
أو مُرسل، رسالة أو مستقبل،
لكن لم يعد هذا الشكل التقليدي
صالحًا للاستعمال.
يجب أن ندخل العامل الثاني،
وهو القفل الثاني الذي يجب أن نوظفة
حتى نفتح الباب في النهاية.
العامل الثاني هو التعبير،
أي التعبير عن أفكارنا.
يقوم الطفل في بداياته بتجميع كلماته ببطىء،
وإذا لم يكن بالكلمات فبالرسم،
أو استخدام معجون اللعب/ الملتينة.
ليس من الممكن أن تذهب اليوم إلى روضة
أو حتى حضانة إلا ويعطونهم معجون يعبرون به.
ثم يتطور الموضوع حيث يريدون أن يتكلموا.
فقد أحضرت الأطفال ذاتهم،
قلت لهم تعالوا، سأحكي لكم قصة.
ولم أكملها.
قلت لهم: “وظفوا خيالكم وعبروا لي برأيكم،
كيف من الممكن أن ننهي القصة؟”
كان لكل طفل رؤيته الخاصة.
إذًا صورة ذهنية ثم التعبير،
ومن ثم الأسلوب.
قلت لكم أن الشكل التقليدي
للإعلام لم يعد يصلح.
يجب أن يوجد أسلوب في تقديم المعلومه.
وهنا نأتي إلى القفل الثالث وهو الإلقاء.
فن الإلقاء الذي يتكون من عاملين:
الكلام المنطوق ولغة الجسد.
كم شخصًا فيكم أسيء فهمه
لأن تعابير وجهه لم تخدمه؟
حسنًا، لماذا نهمل هذا الجانب؟
الكلام المنطوق هو أن أرتب كلامي،
مقدمة جذابة وقصة وأرقام صادمة،
ونسب من الممكن أن تسبب صدمة عند الناس،
والخاتمة التي تبقى في ذهن الناس.
ولكن لدى الجسد أيضًا لغة،
وهي لغة لا نوظفها بالشكل الصحيح.
هل تعرفون أبواب الحديد القديمة؟
يكون لها قفل من الأعلى.
صورة ذهنية ثم تعبير ومن ثم إلقاء.
ويبقى عندنا المفتاح.
أنت صاحب هذا المفتاح.
لا يمكن أن نغير الماضي،
ولكن بإمكاننا أن نرسم المستقبل.
لكن عليك أن ترغب في ذلك أولًا.
يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى  في كتابه العزيز:
“إن الله لا يغير ما بقوم
حتى يغيروا ما بأنفسهم”.
صدق الله العظيم.
شكرًا.
“تصفيق”